live from frankfurt germany
this is rational science and uh
today we have our uninvited guest
and it's this gentleman his name is
timo wygand okay he's a string theorist
and you might ask um who the hell is
timo wygant bill
don't you know he's your employee
he works for you okay you paid for his
schooling
you paid for many of his travel expenses
uh when he went to meetings and um
conferences and lectures and now you're
paying for his salary
now he works uh about half an hour away
from here
in mainz he works at this institute
and it's known as the gutenberg
gutenberg
university okay and gutenberg university
receives lots of funds
i think all of its funds uh from the
government
you might say well bill i don't live in
germany i don't have to pay for anything
that mr wagon uh does
actually you know there's timor wagons
everywhere you're paying for some of
them
in the united states other people pay
for them in china and russia and
everywhere that's one of the issues the
other issue is that all these people
you know they travel and they uh are
invited into conferences and so on
and uh sometimes you know the receiving
party pays for for those
uh trips because they want to hear what
this fall has to say or whatever so
one way or another directly or
indirectly you're paying for
their expenses for their salaries and
even for their education before
you know they got a job so the question
is whether you're
getting your money's worth whether these
people are worth your while
that's one of the issues you want to
think about today okay
and uh so let's find out in more detail
who this man
is he's uh studied physics at
munich and cambridge he did his postdoc
at the university of pennsylvania and
also at slack the stanford linear
accelerator right
um he later on apparently
uh was a professor or did some work at
heidelberg university here's farther
south here in germany
he worked at cern for a while and today
he's working at the mainz institute for
theoretical physics
so he's been around he's uh he knows his
stuff very well more or less like i
talked about the other day about malda
senna
this fellow also is very well versed in
string
theory okay so if you want to know
something about string theory well this
is
one of those uh people whom you want to
listen to okay
okay um here's the other half of uh
his bio it says for many years
researchers have been searching for an
all-encompassing
theory of the universe that unites the
four fundamental forces of nature known
so far
while three of the four forces can be
described uniformly okay
using quantum theory the fourth force
gravity has persistently eluded these
attempts so far and they're referring to
that
thing on the upper left which is known
as the graviton the particle
of um of gravity and they haven't been
able to
incorporate it within quantum mechanics
within the mathematics
of quantum mechanics okay string theory
is a promising approach to also
represent gravity by means of a quantum
model
okay to develop a quantum
gravity and what they're referring to is
they have gravity or so they say they
have
at the cosmic level that's general
relativity
now they're trying to quantize that in
other words they're trying to figure out
some kind of equation
from quantum that matches general
relativity
uh locally okay so that they can somehow
put these
two theories together that they don't
talk to each other general relativity
with quantum mechanics
regarding gravity they don't talk to
each other so they're trying to
merge them in some way okay that's
that's the objective
of string theory and it says uh in the
prisma
program where he works uh he is one of
the uh renowned
experts in the field no doubt about that
and uh they think
string theory is a important important
cornerstone
of theoretical research okay
okay let's find out uh so what does this
thing strengthen you yeah i've never
heard of it
okay let's find out what it is and uh
mr wagon he himself says a lot of this
he says strengthener describes the basic
building blocks of matter
not as a point like not as point-like
particles
but as extended objects okay
in other words what what they're
referring to here is that
uh they're not going to go with a point
particle of
quantum mechanics they're going to
stretch that thing out and turn it into
a line so we can say the
the line particle more or less but it's
really a little more subtle than that i
want to clarify that
you know the point particle uh is not a
point
it's not a dot like there the
two-dimensional dot
that's not what it is and the string of
string theory is not that
uh rectangle elongated rectangle this
that has
width and height uh uh
you know as far as the eye can see with
and height at least
it could have a third dimension no
they're not talking about that they're
they're talking about a one-dimensional
line
just like in quantum you talk about a
zero dimensional particle
so what are they talking about right
there now we have to clarify that
well in quantum mechanics the zero
dimensional particle
is actually a location the point
uh of geometry which is represents a
location
so they've said they can never define
the word point or the word line
very easy very very easy if if
a dot is the point very clear you point
to it and say point
and that's what it what you pointed to
to a dot but if the
dot is something else then it's not a
point
so what is a point well the point is a
location
and of course a location doesn't have
dimensions like width and height
location is a dimensional concept
and so if that's what a particle is a
location
well then what is a line well in other
words of string theory
well what they've done is they they see
the so-called line
of string theory is an itinerary it's a
trajectory
it's motion it's made of not points not
dots
it's made of locations so we should get
rid of one point because it confuses
people
because people think they're talking
about dots
and lines no that's not what they're
talking about they're talking about
locations and itineraries
that's why their so-called lines the
ones that
underlie string theory are
one-dimensional
because what they're saying is it really
has no dimensions
what they have is a number line and the
number line represents
locations and they give numbers to each
one of those locations so they know how
far away they're interested in
how much how far away you are from a
given point from a
frame of reference or whatever so let's
get that straight
we have this line which is not a line
it's an itinerary and that's you know
the geodesics another itinerary the
shortest distance
on a curve and so on so we're talking
about
we're talking about uh itineraries
that's the first thing
this one graviton is a closed-loop
itinerary it's a circle you can think of
it as sorry that maybe that's the best
way to imagine it
okay so you have a closed-loop itinerary
trajectory
motion right we're not talking about the
moon here we're not talking about a
physical object we're talking about
motion
and they claim that this motion vibrates
you know the vibrations of this motion
is the graviton okay so i hope you got
that straight
so the graviton is zero dimensional made
out of a
one-dimensional vibrating motion
okay this is this is how they live
because all equations can only describe
motion
that's the only purpose of an equation
any equation
equation it's a description of motion
like i like to say mathematics
completely all of it
the whole discipline known language it's
not even a decimal it's called the
language
the whole language of mathematics is a
language of
quantitative adverbs that's all that
mathematics is quantitative adverse
there's nothing else
there's no static concept because
whatever static concept you have like
distance
it's measured it's measured with what
with unrolling the measuring tape or
with a clock or whatever
and so there's there's a dynamic
component
to that underlies that that measurement
so all measurements are dynamic so in
physics we have something different
distance is separation between two
objects between the table and the chair
we don't care how much
we just recognize that there is a
separation
period that's not what it is in math in
math you unroll the measuring tape and
say how much
how far away is the table from the chair
or vice versa
okay so let's keep all that in mind
that's the context at the beginning
these were often illustrated as threads
strings and again they're not strings
and gave the theory its name okay yeah
it should be called itineraries or
geodesics or whatever you want to call
them
except anything which is structural you
should not call them lines
or strings or ropes or cables
that's not what these are these are
descriptions mathematical descriptions
adverse quantitative editors of
itineraries
of motion of behavior okay so that's the
first thing you need to
that's the overall picture furthermore
string theory embassages the uh
existence of a ten-dimensional
space-time
oh my god so we have the
four-dimensional so-called
tesseract okay and nobody can imagine
that because what you're staring at
there
is really not two nested cubes
you know and that's the tube one inside
the other and they put it in motion
and that's supposedly the time dimension
we can call it that
that's a number line so what they have
is something moving inside
a cube one cube inside the other cube
they call that four dimensions it's not
it's a three-dimensional
nested pair of nested cubes and
they're in motion okay and they call
that four-dimensional it's really
three-dimensional motion
uh three-dimensional object moving
that's all that is
and the question is how can you imagine
10 dimensions is it
like i show there is is that what they
have in mind i mean what are they
talking about when they say 10
dimensions
okay so uh they clarify that here it is
you get an idea of what he's talking
about here
he says in order to derive statements
about physics in a lower energy range
from strengthening or to make them
experimentally verifiable in this way
physicists have to formulate further
assumptions and develop models
okay models as i like models no problem
how else would it be these are his this
is a direct statement how else would it
be possible to explain that string
theory
in its mathematical description assumes
a 10 dimensional space
but our observable environment has only
four dimensions
three spatial and one temporal is how
tim
weigen describes the challenge okay
that's that's in uh the uh
prima site where he works and so the
question is first he's talking about
description
second he's talking about experimental
verify experimentally verifiable
uh verifiable by whom by the pope i mean
who's going to verify this
this thing uh in other words verifiable
has to do with proof with evidence with
with convincing someone with persuading
someone to change his mind that's what
verifiable means
in science we don't do verification
that's what they do in religion because
they're trying to convince persuade
people
they're trying to get to recruit uh in
sense all we have to do is
explain objectively so that we can
understand the mechanism that you
propose
and again a description is not science
description
i can describe a chair and that doesn't
mean that i know that i'm a scientist
no no a description is not what you need
is an explanation
you need to explain how this universe
works you need to explain how gravity
works
i thought that was the goal at least
right anyways he continues the solution
that he proposes is that six of the ten
dimensions are combined into a compact
unit
that exists in addition to the known
dimensions in string theory this is
called compactification
so they're going to compact or
compactify uh
six of the dimensions because they can't
account for them they claim they can't
account for four of them
but not for the other six and again he
says it there he says you know how
else would it be possible to explain
that string theory is in its
mathematical description assumes a 10
dimensional space
yeah how can you i mean obviously you're
not talking about physics you're talking
about some
imaginary world that you have in your
head and that you're going to describe
with
mathematics but you're not going to be
able to even to describe it physically
or you know make a model of it how can
you make a model of
i mean a physical model of this 10
dimensional world that you're
thinking of what is this is this real or
you know i mean what are we talking
about how can there be ten
perpendicular mutually perpendicular
uh directions we can only imagine three
of them
so you know the universe is
three-dimensional as far as matter is
concerned everything is
three-dimensional i don't know where he
gets the fourth dimension
um maybe he works in a different planet
and he sees a fourth dimensional per
a fourth dimension perpendicular to all
those three
and yeah it's like stephen hawking says
he cannot imagine
this four-dimensional world that they've
created in mathematics
much less can they imagine this
ten-dimensional world
this ten-dimensional space so i don't
know what how they're gonna uh
do a very an experimental verification
of that
okay okay let's continue the solution he
says six of the ten dimensions are
combined into a compact unit okay
and among other things tim wagon's
research focuses on describing this
phenomenon physically
and mathematically again he won't be
able to describe it or
explain it or uh verify it or do an
experiment physically
because it's be it's beyond oh he cannot
even imagine he cannot visualize it much
less
can he do an experiment i mean you know
the way it works
is that if you're ever gonna do a um if
you're gonna do an experiment
the first thing you have to do is design
it it's called design of experiment we
used to shorten it the doe
design of experiment then you can do the
experiment otherwise you know the
manager will not approve the money
because you haven't visualized what
you're trying to accomplish
so the first thing you have to design it
means you got to write it up and maybe
you give a presentation say look this is
what i intend to do fine no problem
then people can understand what you're
going to be doing okay but these people
are saying we can't imagine this 10
dimensional universe
this 10 dimensional space okay yeah
neither can i
and so then what are you talking about
and they're going to verify it
experimentally
you figure it out i mean i i don't know
what they're doing and so again the
question is whether
this is worth your money you're paying
for this guy's salary okay keep that in
mind
and for his travel expenses for his
schooling question was
it worth it okay did you get your
money's worth
okay uh so he continues here he says the
following he says uh all
in all string theory provides us with a
controlled and calculable framework to
study quantum gravity
okay framework okay i don't know what
stuck studying is not enough you need to
produce results
everybody can study and not pass the
test now you got to pass the test
if you're if you're going to give me my
money back in some way if i'm paying for
your schooling for your travel expenses
for your salary
i want something back what are you going
to give me back uh saying that you just
studied
is that it um both from a theoretical
perspective and with regards to the
possibly far-reaching
implications for the description of
physics at lower energies
again a lot of descriptions i want an
explanation i don't hear the word
explanation there
at the same time it opens surprising and
deep connect
connections with mathematics irrelevant
this can also be used to test general
ideas about the structure of quantum
gravity
via string theory okay yeah we want to
know the structure of gravity i mean uh
when we talk about structure hopefully
we're talking about a thing
okay so uh yeah everybody wants to know
what the structure of gravity is you
know what causes gravity that's what
we're after yeah so
i think we're on the same wavelength
there his conclusion
the fundamental question for a unified
theory of all forces of nature
in the context of string theory has
already led to fascinating
um relations between quantum gravity
in general black hole physics and the
geometry of string
compactification spaces and there you
see an example of each we have the
quantum gravity is represented by the
graviton
the um what the black hole famous black
hole you know
they say they claim they took a picture
of it there you see that that's the
representative of general relativity
and then you have this compactification
of spaces which is what
string theory apparently is trying to
elucidate
you know these six really seven because
i don't know where the
fourth dimension is but i've never seen
it i would like someone to draw it for
me
you know 90 degree to the other two to
length and height
i'd love to see that but they say that
they're missing six dimensions they
don't know where they went
okay so find them and then come back
okay please find the six dimensions
uh that go 90 degrees to the other three
okay so that we know what you're talking
about please draw it please bring it to
the conference okay next time
otherwise don't talk about it i mean
what
what is it worth to talk about something
that has no no possibility of even being
imagined
okay so uh mr timur wagon he wrote a few
papers
and i uh framed
something that he said he said this i
think 2011 says
we are string theorists okay we want to
understand what's out there
hey totally in agreement i want to
understand what's out there
what is out there so we need to know
what a what
is what an it is hopefully we're talking
about something real you know something
that's out there
okay outside of us and that means that
we're going to talk about gravity we
need to find out
what causes gravity how mother nature
does that magic trick
of you know very simple you let go of
the pencil okay and it falls to the
floor
we're done that's the only experiment we
need we verified it
okay we verified gravity what is gravity
the pencil falls to the floor
always never falls to the ceiling we're
done we did all the experiments we ever
need to do to understand gravity
uh the description of gravity we're done
now we need to understand it now we need
to find out
what's causing that and hopefully that's
what he's referring to when he says
what's out there
so he writes all these papers here you
have quantum corrections
in four d n equal one infinite distance
limits
uh and the weak gravity conjecture whoa
all this to understand why a pencil fell
to the floor
super symmetric protection in the swamp
land
okay maybe this pencil fell into the
swamp okay
fine uh quasi jacoby
forum forms elliptic genre and strings
in four dimensions
strings in four diamonds emerging
strings from infinite distance limits
and so on you know i mean
okay what is he talking about yeah and
here uh
i pulled some of the jargon from only
from the first paper this is just
from the abstract in his first paper up
there okay
and this is some of the terms that
you'll you need to know in order to
understand string theory
four-dimensional theore theories super
symmetry
decompactification weekly couple
perturbative
gauge threshold renormalization infinite
distance
limits sub the lattice of states and so
on so what was the purpose of
of all this of this paper i mean was it
to figure out how gravity works
and the purpose right there at the
bottom we predict how the masses of this
tower
must be renormalized in order for the
weak gravity conjecture to hold at the
quantum level
what is all that about what is this the
goal is this
the design of experiment this is the
experiment he's going to run somewhere
in a lab and
show this stuff is that is that the goal
is that the purpose
i don't know uh unless you understand it
you know and again only there's only
five people in the world that understand
that language that you just
jargon i mean uh who was it einstein and
later on fine and said the same thing
more or less says you know if you can't
explain it to a barmaid and the other
guy said if you can't explain it to a 10
year old
well you don't know it well enough okay
i don't know if they said it but uh i
like that
that's those statements yeah if you can
explain to a kid
you know how gravity works why this
pencil falls to the floor which is what
we're trying to figure out here right
we're trying to figure out gravity how
gravity works i hopefully
i mean he said he wants to know what's
out there okay so i want to know what's
out there like
what's here or here i mean if there's
something pushing or there's something
pulling
that's what i want to figure out right
because this pencil
falls to the center of the earth and i'm
sure he won't deny that and so the
question is
how does mother nature do that exp that
experiment that trick that magic trick
she does it with nothing with concepts
with mass constant mass with the concept
energy
she does it with a concept field with
the concept charge all these are
mathematical concepts
i can't pull or push with a concept no i
need a physical object you need to
identify the invisible
intangible right physical object that is
in touch with the skin of the pen that's
the objective
not what uh mr wagon just mentioned
there whatever it was okay i forget it
already
okay um he continues oh no um what i
want to show here is that these are the
questions that people ask
like in quora you go to quora there's
what is gravity
that's what people want to know they
don't want to they don't want an
equation they don't want you saying well
look let me take the derivative and then
calculate the
um i don't know the integral they don't
want that
they don't understand any of that 99.99
people on the percent of the people on
the earth
they don't know anything about math and
they could care less about math now they
want just tell me
why this pen falls to the floor
yesterday i dropped the baby he fell on
the floor why did he fall
on the floor i mean what caused him to
fall why didn't he stand my arms letting
him fly upwards no he always falls to
the floor
that's what the people want to know and
so they ask these questions how does
gravity attract materials
what causes gravity do matters
properties have anything to do with
gravity how does gravity work
why do we know what causes gravity why
is there gravity
and it would be nice you know if mr
wagon would go into quora and answer
some of these questions i mean he's an
expert in gravity right or
trying to be be nice if he could answer
some of these questions this is what
people want to know
people don't want to you to just give
them an equation say oh here's the
equation
oh people want an explanation these
people giving them equations description
than any idiotic
irrational papika you know the the
mechanisms they have for
gravity are laughable and it'd be nice
if you could also answer you know by
what physical mechanism does a magnet
attract another i mean here we have
you know two magnets okay
and you know i mean everybody who's
played with magnus realized that there's
already a pole there
it's pulling on me you know from the
inside nothing's pushing on my hands
it's always from the inside
so there's something there something we
can't see or touch but there is
something there
or as mr faraday said um
lines of force those are real there's
something real in there
and maxwell said there is matter in
motion
he was referring to some kind of exotic
matter that we can't see or touch but
there is something in motion
in that region we call field that's what
you got to identify not just use the
word field
word field doesn't tell us anything in
fact it hides more than it tells us we
need to identify what comprises
the field that's the object you need to
identify
and uh since this man is an expert mr
wagon
be nice if he would go to quora and
answer some of these questions
okay
and the other one at the bottom also by
what physical mechanism does an electron
remain bound to a proton i mean he's an
expert in quantum mechanics
hey just tell me what why the electron
doesn't fly away spontaneously
when it's uh in a normal state hydrogen
is a normal state right uh
okay where does the electron just fly
away what keeps it bound to the nucleus
i mean these are simple questions that
i'm sure he would be able to answer
or does mr um wagon believe in this does
he still do
quantum mechanics with this with
transverse 2d waves
does he use magical quantum particles uh
for light is that how he mediates light
and if so how does he mediate
gravity like is he going to use also
gravitons
how do they pull if if they're coming
out one way
you know how is it that they pull is
that his planetary atom is that the one
he's going to use for
current for electricity right at the
bottom okay so so these are the
questions he's got to answer
is are these his foundations for
strength theory because he's going to
use quantum
as a foundation for string theory which
he's going to later on somehow merge
with
with uh general relativity gravity right
the
warping of space time so if this is his
quantum foundations first he's got to
tell me this
he's got to say okay what is light what
is gravity what are you going to use as
a
simulator for especially for gravity
that's what he's trying to explain
what does your atom look like how does
an atom wet shoot a graviton in another
atom okay fine how does it attract it if
it's shooting a graviton
okay and if he says well that's not my
quantum atom well
how do you explain electricity if that's
not your if the planetary model that
warren rutherford
invented if that's not your atom please
explain electricity what is electricity
isn't it the flow of beads from one atom
to another
that means that is your atom you are
using the quantum atom
so uh that's where he's got to start
he's gonna have a an atom to begin with
he doesn't have an atom
he can't give his physical
interpretation he cannot explain gravity
let alone
light or anything else so i don't know
what he's trying to accomplish here this
is where he's got to do the work
not in a bunch of math saying oh look
i've got all these equations i've got
all these
derivatives and and uh integrals yeah
and
please tell me how gravity works that's
what people want to know
and uh we don't have to go to mr wyoming
we can go over his head we go through
someone a little more important than him
someone who won a nobel prize i mean if
you're into uh
what is it into authority
this is one of the man other men to go
to okay
and what did he say i think we i can
safely say that nobody understands
quantum mechanics
and he says do not keep asking yourself
if you can possibly avoid it
but how can it be like that nobody knows
how he can be like that
there's a nobel prize talking to you
okay from the from ultratome
from the ground okay nobody knows how it
can be like that the more you see how
strangely nature behaves the harder it
is to make a model that explains how
even the simplest phenomena
actually work so theoretical physics has
given
up on that
so if theoretical physics meaning
quantum mechanics has given
up on that i'm trying to explain
phenomena
natural phenomena what is mr wagon
up to who what is he trying to do we
need an explanation
and here mr uh final says that they
cannot explain it
and of course mr feynman could not
explain it because he was using
waves and particles that's why he could
not explain it
he had the irrational uh
starting point he had an irrational uh
hypothesis
proposal to begin with you cannot
explain mother nature's
uh workings with waves or particles
and ask why they ended up with
irrational explanation that's why they
cannot explain
the invisible world out there how mother
nature does her things
that's where the problem is and here we
have another gentleman he's still alive
okay and his name is suskind leonard
suskin
he's uh from stanford and he said modern
science is difficult and often
counter-intuitive well only if
you're a mechanic if you do it with
particles or waves then it's
counterintuitive
where intuition and common sense fail
they had to create new forms of
intuition
new forms of intuition mainly through
the use of abstract mathematics i don't
know what that helps
okay but when common sense fails
uncommon sense must be created
so they have uncommon sense in
mathematics okay human cognition does
not operate according to principles of
common sense
uh mr suskin is saying that father
universe
does not agree with our way of thinking
here us humans because
he runs the universe in such a way that
we cannot understand it and all we can
do is through mathematics more or less
describe it
and forget about explaining it like mr
feinen just said and here's another
statement from mr suskin just in case
okay and you're doubles up on that and
he says the following says
you and i evolved in a world of three
dimensions yeah
true we can't visualize more dimensions
i can visualize three dimensions in my
head but i use x y and z
to describe them mathematically okay
fine you describe them with x y and z no
problem
now i go to four diamonds or five
dimensions i can't visualize them
anymore i can't say now close your eyes
and view in your head five dimensions
because i can't do it either
so we're stuck needing mathematics
because evolution
didn't equip us to be able to visualize
quantum mechanics
it didn't equip us to visualize 11
dimensional space times
evolution did this to us
so once again i asked what is mr weigan
trying to do
we hear we have more senior members
in fact uh suskin is a strength theorist
and these people are saying you forget
about quantum mechanics forget about
visualizing any of this forget about
even imagining this but you cannot
imagine that's why you can't draw it you
can't make a picture of it in fact you
go to any of these papers that this
individual wrote and you won't find a
single picture
and so the question is you see he's
going to produce
experimental evidence to try to verify
something
how are you going to verify something
like gravity which is invisible
and intangible and more yet how can you
visualize it when you
simulate them with particles with
discrete particles one way
particles particles that only travel one
direction
and with that you're supposed to produce
the attraction of gravity
what is mr wagon trying to do i mean he
can do all the calculations he wants
what does it help us and so let me let
me give you a little um
a little for instance here a little
example okay
this is the famous black hole that they
found out there this is
this is a black hole right and that you
say well you know um
what is a black hole and they'll tell
you well it's a star that
had so much mass a lot of mass much more
than our sun
and it collapsed because of its own
gravity to a point where at some point
it exploded and left behind
um you know just got rid of its skin so
to speak
what left behind something that kept
shrinking because of the enormous mass
you had all these very heavy elements
comprising that little ball
it just kept shrinking shrinking
shrinking shrinking until it was no more
no volume no radius no diameter no size
no nothing okay now a lot of people
don't don't understand that people say
well
black hole never goes to nothing because
if they said that a lot of people would
question that right
so they say no it just becomes very tiny
unimaginably
small infinitesimally small okay
that's the way they put it to you well
um
so this is this is how the black hole is
created here you can see it it's
uh what's left behind is this uh thingy
there this little ball and supposedly
not even the ball remains because that's
supposed to be just a singularity
that to which this entire mass collapsed
to right so that's essentially what it
looks like or the
notion that they want to give you and
the picture here that supposedly they
uh hold it or is it here
this picture it just gives you an idea
of what they're thinking
they're saying that's a black hole okay
that's what it should look like and
that's the picture supposedly that they
took a picture of a couple years ago and
got a nobel prize for okay
turns out that you know again the black
hole is zero dimension
it collapses to zero size and here are a
couple of
testimonies okay the black hole radius
is zero
which means its density is infinite and
all these are professors uh they're all
phds
saying this okay so this is what they
learned in college you can agree with
them or disagree with them i'm just
saying there's a lot of people out there
professionals who actually believe yeah
black hole is zero dimensional and they
just repeat it
and never they never ponder what they're
saying i mean how can it be zero
dimensional what are you talking about
then
black holes are the evolutionary
endpoints of stars at least
10 to 15 times as massive as the sun if
a star that massive or larger undergoes
a supernova explosion
it mainly behind a fairly massive
burned-out stalled remnant with no
outward forces to oppose gravitational
forces
the remnant will collapse in on itself
the star
eventually collapses to what to the
point of zero volume
and infinite density okay creating what
is known as a singularity
that's from nasa okay that's from their
site
now you know you were talking about
professors we're talking about
an institution here okay uh more
evidence you need more evidence you're
not convinced yet okay
here it is uh let's put over here
here's another one it says uh what is a
black hole is it uh big is it
is it humongous in size no it's zero
dimensional zero d
no dimensions no size no radius no no
any no diameter
in theory it's not the size of a pinhead
but actually has zero
size a true mathematical point uh
professor who teaches this at ohio state
a collapsing star
stellar core with n mass greater than
three uh
the sun will become a black hole okay if
the initial mass of a star is greater
than 20
uh mass of the sun or so since it is too
massive to become a neutron star the
dense core collapses totally
okay nothing can stop its info according
to the laws of physics taken to their
logical conclusion
it becomes a singularity what is a
singularity singularity is a
point which has zero radius and infinite
density
fortunately for the sanity of
astronomers it is impossible to see
a singularity no kid we're talking about
nothing that's what these people are
talking about they're saying there is a
nothing out there
a non-existent structure and they call
that a singularity and that's
that's the heart of the black hole
so and that's what mr wagon studies or
plans to
somehow merge with the quantum mechanics
that he cannot even
uh justify the foundations of you know
the what is light what is gravity what
does an atom look like what is
electricity
what is magnetism you know he cannot
justify any of those he's already gone
past that he said oh that was high
school
what they call gymnasium here no he's
further on now he's up there uh he's
talking about string theory
well you should come back to high school
and explain it to the high schoolers
and it's okay so we need more authority
maybe let's put some authority here i
mean you're not going to get more
authority than stephen hawking
and he says that chandrasekhar got a
nobel prize for what for
for showing that a black hole
could collect which is big enough would
collapse to zero size
and eddington was the supervisor of
chandrasekhar
while he was studying in england and
eddington thought it was simply not
possible that he started
collapsed to a point einstein himself
wrote a paper in which he claimed that
stars would not shrink to
what zero size and then
uh and this is on his book a brief
history of time he says hawking says
however he was awarded the nobel prize
in 1983 for his early work on limiting
mass
of cold stars chandrasekhar had shown
that the exclusion principle could not
halt the collapse of a star more massive
than the chandrasekhar
limit okay still unconvinced well
there's one more here
and it's another indian fellow and he
uh he's a very important uh fellow
over there in india and he says the
following let me just put this
oh let me get this right
and he says the following okay he says
on solving the equation with a
particular value
row of central density you will get a
model of a star with mass
m and radius r plot r as a function of
m and show that r falls to zero when
m is equal to the chandrasekhar mass our
radius goes to zero right if you can do
all these then you have repeated the
calculation for which
chandrasekhar won the nobel prize
so we have mr chandrasekhar and he won
the nobel prize for
proving that uh black holes are zero
dimensional can be
at least if the star is big enough it
can um
it'll shrink to the point where it's got
zero damage
so a lot of people uh do not understand
that they they think uh
that's nonsense and they say that that's
not a black hole black hole is more than
zero dimensional
because as you saw in the picture it's
got this black circle in there and they
say well that's more than zero dimension
so obviously a black hole is not zero
dimensions
but these people are all telling you
it's zero dimensions singularity is
there in those
zero dimensions it collapsed to nothing
all structure
has been crushed out of existence and
all that remains is a mathematical
singularity
mathematical singularities don't have
radius
don't have size don't have diameter
don't have volume there's nothing
there it's just all mass infinite mass
because
there's no volume and according to the
equation you know uh
you have infinite infinite uh mass
infinite
because uh there is you know the there's
no volume
okay um
here's another testimony that reinforces
that
uh these people are also uh professors
okay just so you know that i'm not
i'm pulling their words here okay and
they all say the same thing that a black
hole crushes
matter all matter that falls into a
black hole crushes it out of existence
there you see it
crushed out of existence everywhere okay
so
black hole there's nothing there
absolutely nothing there
because any structure any atom that went
in there that any particle that fell in
there
was crushed out of exist there is no
structure it's only mass that's the only
property
aside from charge and uh angular
momentum but
forgetting about that all men all black
holes all of them have
mass that's it and what is mass uh
the quantity of matter and the black
hole has crushed all matter out of
existence
so i don't even know if it has mass
because mass is the quantity of matter
or a measure of the quantity of matter
which has now been crushed out of
existence all we have is a mathematical
number calculation
that's all we that's all that is
contained within a black hole
and even if we grant that let's say that
it's got
tons of mass tons of kilograms no
problem
how does that mass pull on a star far
away and force it to go around itself
i mean you gotta explain that mechanism
also it's not enough to say oh it's mass
well yeah so what is the mechanism
are you gonna do the uh warp space uh
canvas the fishnet
is is that the mechanism yeah
and to top it off we get a definition of
what a black hole is okay here it is
what is a
black hole it's a region that's what it
is it's a region
region is a concept uh the region of
your hand the palm is a region of your
hand
china is a region of the planet okay
so region is always of something else
and in this case black hole supposedly
is a region of space time or space
so uh region is a concept we're not it's
not a physical object that you can hold
in your hand or touch or anything like
that no
this is a mathematical concept and it's
known as a region because in that region
something happens
that's all they know that's how vague
the definition of a black hole is
and so that's an abstract con concept
lacking body or size of course that's
why it has
no volume no size no anything no concept
has size i mean love what is the size of
love i mean is it two centimeter
i don't know you know some have longer
love
bigger diameters of love a black hole is
not a tangible object but a region in
space
max planck institute okay and a black
hole is a region one seems to land in
paradoxes if one thinks of them as
things
it's not a thing it is therefore
problematic to think of the singularity
as having location
obviously if it's got it's it's not a
thing it cannot have location the
concepts don't have location he wrote
that uh in 2009 he modified
that in 2019 for the stanford
encyclopedia philosophy
now he says the following he said black
holes although they are nothing more
than regions
appear to become the thermodynamical
entities with a temperature and entropy
blah blah blah blah blah
one runs into difficulties if one tries
to define singularities
as things they have that have locations
yeah you can't have location unless you
have a thing you need
you need uh location uh you need a thing
to have location or motion
there is no such thing as motion without
a thing there's no such thing as
location without a thing you need the
thing
what these people do is they remove the
thing they replace it with a dot
they call a point which is zero
dimensional which is not really a dot
which is not a point which is really a
location
location of what maybe the center of
mass or center of charge or whatever of
the object that you're
dealing with so they forget about the
object they throw it away and they say
we're just going to deal with
the charge or the mass or whatever so
they talk about kilograms they don't
talk about
objects and here's another uh
testimony as far as uh region there you
see it
that's what a black hole is it's a
region of space
that's it so we're talking about a
region so what you're staring at
is not a thing i mean you know a hole
if you don't have the ground like bugs
bunny wants to get inside the hole he's
got to have ground the hole
is in the ground you have to identify
the ground in this case uh you can say
space if you treat space as a physical
object and what you created a hole in
space
you ripped it so uh this is so realistic
at this point okay so here it is
let me give you this uh this analogy
so that you can take it to the bank with
you okay here's your famous black hole
okay this is where we start
we're going to replace this black hole
just to show what mr
wagon does okay we're going to replace
it with this we're gonna replace it with
heaven okay so now we had a black hole
we're gonna replace
the black hole with heaven and here we
have
the graviton okay which is the string
version of the
graviton and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna replace it with this we're
gonna replace it with the soul going to
heaven
okay let me tell you where i'm going
with all this
okay where am i going i'm saying that
you know and you can create also by the
way you could create
just like mr uh wagon did we create uh
you know fancy language
to talk about all this you know you can
say oh you know trump's
transubstantiation or some fancy word
like that which five people in the world
maybe know about
and that's it you know nobody after that
can follow them because these people
speak their own language there and you
say bill why are you using us in an
analogy
okay let me show you why let me show you
why because we're trying to figure out
what mr weigan
is doing whether he's worth your while
whether he's uh
you know if if you really want to
contribute to his
uh further studies okay or
people who work in string theory in
general okay so here's uh
mr wagon he says look i've calculated
you know how fast a person can go into
heaven i calculated a derivative
that shows you you know it's a change in
um in one parameter with respect to
another
okay or he can say look i've got the
integral for heaven
i can tell you what the
surface or what the area or the volume
of heaven
is because i've calculated it okay so he
gives you some fancy equation there and
he says look this is what i'm working on
and you say well
uh timo uh
but i don't think souls go to heaven and
i don't think there is a heaven i don't
even think there is a god
and so here you tell me that you're
making all these equations to calculate
how a soul goes to heaven
or what the size of heaven is and you're
going to calculate
you know what happens at the edge of
heaven and when the
soul crosses the boundary into heaven
and i mean are we talking to something
real here i mean i i don't think there
is a soul that flies to heaven i don't
think there is a heaven i don't think
there's a god out there
and he says you don't believe in god you
don't believe in heaven
my god where have you been all these
years
everybody believes in god everybody
believes in heaven
who the hell are you bill i mean to
question the existence of god where did
you get that
and i'm saying well where did you get
god i mean where did where did you
figure out that there is a heaven and
that there is a soul that goes to heaven
okay and he might say well i got it from
a nobel prize winner
in fact he won the nobel prize this year
okay
that's this gentleman here if i can find
him here
his name is uh mr reinhard gensel in
fact i wrote about him
in the past or a paper on him the
outstanding
main result of our work this fellow
works for the max planck institute he's
one of the head hunches there
the outstanding main result of our work
is the proof of existence
of an astrophysical i modified it a
little bit i've edited
newspaper i hope he doesn't mind okay
i'm an astrophysical
heaven beyond any reasonable doubt
an unambiguous proof of the existence of
heaven as defined by general relativity
requires
the determination of the gravitational
potential to the scale of the event
horizon
this proof can in principle be obtained
from spatially resolved measurements of
the motion of
test spirits in close orbit around the
nucleus
in practice it is not possible yet to
probe the scale of an event horizon
of any heaven candidate with spatially
resolved dynamic
dynamical measurements a more modest
goal then is
to show that the gravitational potential
of a galaxy nucleus
is dominated by a compact non-stellar
mass and that this central mass
concentration cannot be
anything but heaven hey that's what
uh mr genzo uh won the nobel prize for
this year he proved the existence of
black holes
and he proved it indirectly he says look
what else could it be
i mean you know that's that's his that's
his conclusion
where did he get this i mean uh where
does all this come from because he wrote
this
many years later after someone allegedly
okay discovered
the first black hole and that was mr tom
bolton he's given
credit for that i think he's canadian
and mr bolton
found this he was looking at a region of
space called cygnus x1
the swan and he found a star there
and he says it's moving around okay but
the star is orbiting around nothing
and he calculated the orbit the distance
all this stuff he said oh i know what
happened here
there's a black hole somewhere in
between there and he put it in there by
hand he says there's the black hole okay
so this is how
he visualized that and since then in
1970s
just about everyone you know accepted
that black holes were real and then
mr ganzo comes a couple decades later
and says oh we proven the existence of
black hole what else could it be
so this is their their proof their proof
is you know the the curtain moves
and you say what else could it be it's
got to be the spirit of my grandmother
well maybe if you close the window you
know i mean it stops moving
but by then i guess grandma went through
back to heaven you know
yeah the issue is is that the only uh
explanation for why a star moves
okay and so let's find out if we can um
if we can do better
oh there's one other issue here before i
go
to this uh another issue that they say
is that you know they found that
um gases from a star are sucked in by
there you see the black hole but
they see a nothing in there but they say
what else could it be except the black
hole sucking in
all this gas from a star okay from the
surface of a star it just goes to
nowhere and so they say well that
nowhere is the black hole
so it's not only that a star revolves
around nothing
but also that the um skin of a star is
being sucked up
by something in there and they don't
know what it is because they can't see
anything in there and they say well the
only thing that can do that
is a black hole okay so that's the
reason it's always
indirectly okay they never saw a black
hole touch the black hole none of that
now they go in there they look and they
say well
what else could it be that's the reason
well let's find out uh
what else it could be let's show them
what we can do here on earth
to show that there is another mechanism
here you see one of them
you put a charged ball in a magnetic
field
and it'll go around in circles just like
a star does
right so it's not only through black
holes that you can create this
effect you can do it also with a
magnetic field coming down
a uh a charged ball and
uh here you see the gas version okay
you can see smoke being sucked up by a
rotating magnetic field
so they have this magnetic field and it
just sucks up
the smoke which is a gas particles there
right so uh
we don't need a black hole to explain
what happens out there
in space we can do it with a magnetic
field
whatever magnetic field is right now
we're not going to get into that okay
but whatever magnetic field is it can
produce these same effects and you can
do it out there in
in um in space in in the cosmos
so here let me show you a different
version of the so-called black hole
and we start with a galaxy okay here's a
galaxy okay
and you can see it rotating okay now
what we don't see is the magnetic field
of the galaxy so let's
see if we can put that in there okay
here it is the magnetic field of the
galaxy
in rational science we do that with reds
okay but right now we're not gonna get
into that
and okay and so let's look at why a star
would be moving around in circles
okay there you see the little star at
the bottom almost in the center there
that's moving around
and right at the upper left-hand corner
you see the what i showed earlier the um
the little ball in the magnetic field so
if the
magnetic field of the galaxy is coming
down about on this charged
object you know it's uh got a magnetic
field that little star there
and so if it primarily is strong in that
region of the galaxy the magnetic field
then it would do this it would do
exactly
what you're seeing there would move it
around nothing not that not because it's
moving around the center that's got a
lot of mass
but because you have a magnetic field
bearing down on this charged object
okay and then um how about the smoke
same thing here here we get the
the gases from a um promo star okay
and again you can see it there uh
if if uh you see that the gases from the
skin of a star are being sucked up by
nothing well that just as well can be
done by what you see there it's done by
a magnetic field that can just as well
uh
skin a star alive so to speak okay
so we can produce this in in the cosmic
scenario without any black holes we do
not need black holes to explain
these phenomena we have another
explanation for that and of course for
that you have to change your assumptions
that's what you need to do
and mr wagon has no assumptions anyways
he's relying on the assumptions
of quantum mechanics which are
irrational we haven't been able to
explain
anything in the last 10 000 years a
single phenomena
of the invisible world of mother
nature's with either particles or with
transverse waves waves we've only had
for 400 years
but waves and transfer transverse waves
and particles
neither one can explain the invisible
world of mother nature
okay and so that's where we we have to
change the assumptions
so what do we change well here it is
closing arguments here
uh first one is that um
what do i want to show here no let me
let me just skip that one otherwise it's
going to be too long
this is this is these are the
assumptions that need to be changed by
the people who do quantum mechanics
okay they should stop doing particles
they should stop doing waves
and what do we propose instead well we
propose that all atoms in the universe
are physically
interconnected we don't have a sandbox
we don't have a
beehive with all the bees buzzing around
we don't have individual discrete
entities what we have is all atoms in
the universe are physically
interconnected
uh what interconnects them well what
interconnects them is the mediator of
light
which looks uh wrong yeah which looks
more or less like this
so far at the bottom i gotta pull them
all the way up okay looks more or less
like this okay we have
a single thread in the entire universe
that constitutes all the matter
okay and this thread uh turns into all
these atoms that are buzzing around us
we're made of them as well that's why we
have a single thread in the universe and
it coils around itself
and produces you know the
electromagnetic ropes
that bind every atom in fact every atom
is
made of the same threads that
comprise the ropes that interconnect
them so there's a single thread in the
entire universe and it's a new model
and with that we can explain you know
gravity we can explain
physically we give you a physical
interpretation we give you a picture
something you can sink your teeth into
sometimes you can understand just by
watching the pictures
because it's it's a it's it's a
realistic model
we just need to abandon the particle and
wave models that's it but what we're
talking about we can explain
you know magnetism gravity the behavior
of light
electricity the behavior of the atom etc
all the invisible stuff
which quantum right now cannot explain
as mr feynman just said
uh no one can figure that out yeah under
particles you can't figure it out you
need to change the hypothesis
instead of applying paparian
falsifiability where they needed it
they didn't that's where they did not
apply for paperion falsifiability
here was the the lost opportunity they
should have said well holy we can't
explain a single experiment all
experiments debunk
quantum mechanics the particle model we
have to get rid of the particle model
now they just created more principles to
accommodate the particle
so you got the principle of
complementary duality you have the
principle of
uncertainty and so on so they included
principles to accommodate the particle
instead of getting rid of the particle
okay so um what can i say about mr wagon
well uh he's like a chess player
you know um grand master he enjoys
playing
uh chess does that every day
is that good for anything well no it's
it's entertainment i mean you know you
go in there you play chess every morning
and you love it you play all these
different games they all boy it's
beautiful
what a beautiful move i made here today
one that i came up with and so on
and it's very it in it's you know you
get enthusiastic about it because you
can
discover me uh movements
of your pawns and your rooks and so on
and you like those moves you say oh that
was smart look i did it this way instead
of doing it that way so you learn
and it's great what does
chess produce it produces absolutely
nothing other than
entertainment especially for the guy who
you know is a grandmaster who does this
uh every day you know you're gonna
support that you're gonna say well you
know i'm gonna
support chess all over the world no
that's something that
they should do because it's like a game
for them and they love it and they'll
that's great you know no no problem just
do your thing over there but don't tell
me
that because you play chess you know
physics or that you can
understand how this universe works and
mr wagon is no different
he enjoys doing his calculations his
math
his uh derivatives and uh
integrals he loves that stuff he's
applying it to what to what soul's going
to heaven
to the volume of heaven is that what
he's applying it to
we don't care he if he believes in that
stuff
well he should found a church and not
use government funds
to do his stuff unless he can justify
that that has
something to do with science and with
physics right now we're paying this
fella
and many others like him okay i'm
picking on him but he's representative
of a lot of people out there
that you're paying their salaries you're
paying their education you're paying
directly or indirectly also for them to
go into conferences and so on
what do these people produce they're
producing equations
what are those equations on on gravitons
which
they cannot justify you know we're
talking about a mathematical concept not
a physical object
out there you cannot explain with
gravitons why the pen falls to the floor
or they apply it to general relativity
warp space
which again there is no such monster as
warp space especially there's no such
monster as warp time
because they're saying that you know
you're warping space time that means
you're warping time
gravity warps time and that's the reason
the earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
so yeah i gotta take that literally
because uh you're telling me that the
earth doesn't fly out because there's a
war
wall of time that prevents it from
leaving the solar system
that's why i got to take it literally
otherwise you gotta explain why the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system
you gotta give me a physical mechanism
you can't say well you know
god works in mysterious ways not a good
answer in physics
so if mr um wagon likes to do
calculations he likes to do his little
chess game he calls it calculations uh
string theory whatever he calls it
fine do it on your own time on your own
money and do it in your own club your
own
church your own sunday school don't
bring it into physics
has nothing whatsoever to do with
physics it cannot explain gravity in any
way shape or form
never has never will and for sure you're
not going to be able to run an
experiment to verify
your predictions because you're talking
about ten dimensional whatevers
six of them which are hidden maybe
curled into one another as they say
uh you can barely deal with the three
dimensions of
physical physics okay and then he's
dealing with a graviton which is what
a one-dimensional line no
one-dimensional not even one dimension
it's just an itinerary they call
one-dimensional he's talking about a
number line
this number line shakes vibrates and
creates a
a moving a vibrating itinerary that's
what it is
he's vibrating an itinerary he calls out
a particle with that vibrating itinerary
he plans to produce
the force of pull of gravity no
absolutely nonsense
all of it 150 of it none of that
survives rationality
and instead of that he should i mean i
wouldn't mind contributing to his
uh treasury if he would at least go into
quora and answer some of the questions
baby stuff you know that people ask like
what is gravity
how does a magnet attract another
if he could answer those questions then
maybe he's worth as well